e
the house will come to
order the chair recognizes a member from
Auburn representative Osborne who moves
the house adjourned from the session
February 13th 2025 you ready for the
question all those in favor say I those
oppos nay the eyes happen the house is
adjourned the house will attend to a
Prayer by house chaplain Reverend
Jonathan Hopkins pastor at Concordia
conquer good
pray dear God we pray this day for good
government for democracy alive in our
country and our state we are thankful
this day for people called to serve the
people of the State of New Hampshire we
ask you to be with this body today as
they set about their business we pray
that they may uphold the highest
standards standards of their office we
pray that in making and passing of
legislation we may govern well by caring
for all human life and happiness that
within this chamber we might preserve
the Peace of our fellow citizens promote
their prosperity and happiness
cultivate a spirit of cander moderation
charity and forbearance towards one
another help us to be sober in our
deliberation so that government does for
people only what they cannot do better
by themselves and no more help us never
forget that government is we the people
and not an alien power over us the
ultimate rulers of our democracy are not
a president Senators congressmen
government officials but the voters of
the chair recognizes a member from
Greenland representative Dennis Malloy
allegiance
Al the United States of America
the
stands
indivisible andice for
all the chair recognizes Emily and
[Music]
angum by the
dawn
light would so proud
[Music]
we the
GLE stripes and bright
stars through
theous
fight
the
we were so
G string
and the
rocket
red the bombs
bur
in give proof through the
night a flag was still
yet
W oh the
free and
the of
the pra
[Applause]
the house will attend to a request for
leaves of absence Mr Speaker the day
illness Representatives beler D faler
Molly Howard Mills Pressa Jeffrey Smith
sfus Brian Sullivan Terry vanney w ER
the day important business
Representatives Dupont and
verville these lead will happens that we
granted unless otherwise ordered by the
house the house will attend to the
introduction of guests Mr Speaker please
welcome Miriam dumit and Tyler Sanders
students from gtown high school our
[Applause]
Mr Speaker please welcome Adam Arya and
ardan shran husband and children of the
singer guests of Representative Malloy
The Honorable John sski former member
from Bedford and Amanda sski guests of
Representative gold Wendy Larson and
Maggie ball guests of Representative
Balboni Oscar vases guest of
representative jurus Tom mcmanis guest
of Representative maor Christine Summers
wife of Representative Summers and
representatives from New Hampshire life
science guest of the speaker they are
with us in the gallery
today Welcome to the New Hampshire
[Applause]
house the house will now attend to the
consent
calendar Mr Speaker there are no bills
calendar are there any other bills to be
removed from the consent calendar
representative Osman moves that the
consent calendar with the relevant
amendments as printed in this st's house
record be adopted are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppos nay the eyes haven't consent
calendar is adopted under rules of the
house from the committee on criminal
justice and Public Safety HB 506 FN is
referred to the committee on finance the
committee on education policy and
administration HB 671 FNA is referred to
the committee on finance from the Comm
committee on environment and agriculture
HB 658 FN is referred to the committee
on Ways and Means and from the committee
on Ways and Means HB 650 FN is referred
finance the house will now attend to the
regular
calendar majority the committee on
science technology and energy to which
was referred House Bill 169 FN act
relative to a quorum of the Public
Utilities Commission having considered
the same Report with the same following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate representative Doug Thomas
from the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following Amendment recommend and
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with Amendment sen Thomas Corman
for the minority of the committee chair
Corman chair recognize represent of
Corman thank you Mr Speaker I'm over
here on the other side I figured I'd see
here Mr Speaker one commissioner does
not a commission make the commission I'm
referring to is the Pu the Public
Utilities Commission the Pu sets the
rates for the regulated utilities it
also makes various
Rules by Statute the Pu comprises three
Commissioners one of whom chairs the
commission also by Statute the Pu chair
has the same powers and abilities and
duties as any Commissioner of an
executive department these powers
include Ru making which is what this
bill is about current statute says that
the Pu chair can make rules on their own
regardless of whether the other two
Commissioners agree with the
rules this bill says that when the puc
adopts rules at least two of the
Commissioners must agree to these rules
because one commissioner does not a
commission
make the only opposition to this bill
and testimony came from the Pu now
that's because the bill as introduced
also says that when the Pu holds a
hearing at least two Commissioners must
be present the Pu testified that they
often have just one commissioner present
at a hearing and sometimes just staff
and no Commissioners they said that they
would need a special commissioner on
retainer which would create an
expenditure okay I responded with an
amendment that eliminates the
expenditure it's 0249 on pages 34 and 35
of the House calendar it takes just just
a few seconds to read hint hint the
amendment leaves the current practice
for hearings unchanged so that no
special commissioner on retainer is
needed and hence no expenditure and
simply says that rules must be adopted
by a majority of the Pu a majority means
at least two Commissioners even if
positions are vacant again one
commissioner does not a commission make
at the executive session the majority of
our committee refused to even discuss
this amendment much less vote on it I
ask the body to overturn the itl motion
so that we may consider this simple
amendment that requires a majority of
the Pu Commissioners to adopt rules I
also want to address the majority
reports objection to the bill defining
the Pu as a regulatory
agency the puc adopts rules but does not
enforce them how do I know the Pu chair
told us so during an informational
presentation to our committee last month
a slid mentioned enforcement and I asked
pu chairman goldner to elaborate here is
what he said quote so what I meant to
say was that the enforcement element and
audit element in that slide went over to
the doe that's the department of energy
so there was no enforcement there is no
audit within the current pu so I had
meant to say that they had shifted over
to the Department of energy unquote so
the puc is indeed a regulatory agency I
ask my colleagues to overturn the itl
motion so that we may consider the
amendment and make it clear that one
commissioner does not a commission make
again I ask you to please take a few
seconds really just a few seconds to
read Amendment 0249 starting on page 34
of the calendar thank you Mr Speaker and
Mr Speaker I request a division
Thomas well thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker I'm sure you'd be
happy to know that we're not going to be
talking about energy technology or
science on this bill we're really
talking more about common sense which
this Bill acts
Mr Speaker it is true that current law
does not require Commissioners to be at
ordinary public hearings or any meetings
where there's no binding vote it is true
that they have uh people called staff
examiners that will listen to public
hearings and they'll provide these notes
and transcripts to the Commissioners so
that when it does come time for a
binding vote as the law requires two
Commissioners must be present for that
binding vote to do otherwise like this
bill implies would merely delay greatly
a lot of proceedings imagine we only
have three Commissioners so if two can't
make an ordinary public hearing and they
have to delay it it could be weeks
before that public hearing is is done
further delaying pu action so it makes
sense in this case that we don't require
two Commissioners to be at every single
meeting that this bill would require re
ired it's common
sense so and although in the past where
in some cases where binding votes are
required the Pu has had to hire an extra
commissioner to fill in at that time at
some expense this bill would require one
to be held on standby virtually every
time there might be any type of a
gathering or meeting of the Pu further
incurring more
expense again it makes sense not to do
that and of course the one person that
did require this bill was the Office of
Consumer Advocate and the primary
sponsor and they were the only people to
speak on this bill and the Bill had very
little public
support so I would say that we instead
of complicating and delaying the puc's
action we should in fact take the common
sense approach let's press the green
button and it itail this Bill thank you
Mr Speaker
representative Thomas has requested a
division members take your seats this
clear the motion before us is the
majority report of inexpedient to
legislator and House Bill 169 this is a
division vote chair recognized
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that
governing bodies at all
levels such as Town select boards school
boards City
councils our state's Public Utilities
Commission
and countless other local state and
federal committees and commissions are
composed of multiple
members to ensure that a diverse range
of perspectives and expertise are
brought to bear on the decisions they
make and if I
know that current New Hampshire statute
is being interpreted to allow a single
member of our three member Public
Utilities Commission to issue rules
dictating policy and practice for our
State's numerous regulated Public
Utilities affecting every single
resident and business of our state
regardless of whether the other two
Commissioners
agree with that rule or even have been
consulted on
it would I then press the red button to
defeat the itl motion so that a floor
Amendment to the bill can be
heard chair recognize represent sneller
thank you Mr
Speaker if I would know that this bill
would necessitate hiring a special
standby public utilities commissioner
simply to be available on call at an
annual salary of well into the six
figures range would I now to press the
green button to say no to this huge and
unnecessary expense thank you Mr Speaker
make sure everybody turns your buttons
on Miss machines on so we can
vote the motion before us is a majority
committee report of index meting to
legislator on House Bill 169 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
all members president opportunity to
vote 203 voting aay 160 voting a
majority of the committee on science
technology and energy to which was
referred House Bill 504 act relative
through the state energy policy having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with
Amendment representative Les berinsky
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same be anable to agree
with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Dale Swanson for the minority of the
committee the amendment is 0215 H pred
in house Record 12 page 38 are you ready
for the question on the amendment all
those in favor say I I those oppos
nay the eyes have it the amendment is
adopted the chair now recognizes
Speaker Democrats on the science
technology and energy committee feel
that this new
statement of energy policy for our state
misses the mark in the following
Ways by including the
phrase to ensure the state's energy
Independence this policy ignores the
inescapable fact that New Hampshire is
actually one of the most dependent
states in the country when it comes to
energy which leaves our residents and
businesses constantly exposed and
vulnerable to perturbations in world
energy markets from extreme weather
events accidents War acts of terrorism
or geopolitical changes anywhere in the
world at the same time it fails to
acknowledge that the only energy
resources we do have within our
Borders or potentially off our
Shores Renewables like solar biomass
hydropower and wind
do contribute substantially to our
state's energy
security and
affordability in that when they're
flowing which is
often they displace the need to burn the
aforementioned
limited imported fossil
fuels by reducing demand for natural gas
substantially every
day they reduce the regional clearing
price of electric electricity and lower
costs for
everyone with its emphasis on reliable
OnDemand and firm
resources the policy statement in hp504
clearly nods toward large centralized
power plants and the 20th century
electric grid and it ignores the 21st
century Trend toward the proliferation
of distributed energy
resources modernization of the grid to
support two-way energy
flows and the fact that in an energy
system all the components have
value contribute to the system's
characteristics the new statement fails
to acknowledge that New Hampshire's
energy security truly lies in
acknowledging and embracing its
interdependence
with the other states in New England the
Northeast and even Canada interconnected
in a regional grid that provides our
state's distribution utilities with
access to power flowing from all across
the
region look Democrats acknowledge that
we'll be burning fossil fuels in New
Hampshire for a long time none of us
want to Outlaw gasoline powered vehicles
or fossil fuel burning furn FES or
boilers tomorrow or even a decade from
now but we do advocate for policies that
will
slowly over
decades as the emergence of new and
improving technology
allows reduce our dependence and our
vulnerability to Global fossil fuel
markets reduce the environmental harm
and health problems that fossil fuel
combustion caus
cuses and increase our energy security
and economic Vitality by emphasizing the
energy we can generate here in New
Hampshire HB 504's policy statement is
narrow-minded and largely
backward-looking so I urge you to vote
no on
otpa and Mr Speaker I request a division
perne thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
last year this body passed a similar
Bill HB 1623 on a roll call vote the
first part the first part of that bill
updated the state energy policy and the
second part provided protections for
instate electrical generation capacity
when that bill reached the other body
they removed the energy policy updates
and only the generator protections were
eventually adopted into state law the
bill in front of you now is a slightly
improved version of that first part the
energy policy
update with a little bit of the
background out of the way why do we need
to update the state energy policy to
keep my testimony short I'll give you
just a few of the most important changes
the existing policy states that we
should meet our energy needs at the
lowest possible price while providing
for reliability and energy diversity but
there's no guidance on how to balance
those opposing constraints the updated
policy explicitly stipulates that market
forces market-based mechanisms and
customer Choice should drive prudent
energy use customer policy states that
current policy states that we should
maximize the use of Energy Efficiency
and other demand side resources the new
policy prescribes that we should do
those things according to Market
principles and by focusing on Market
transformation
in cases where there is a significant
need for government to intervene in the
energy Market the new policy stipulates
that any intervention should be quote
Tim limited narrow and necessary to
achieve a specific policy goal end quote
the new policy also acknowledges that a
significant risk to State energy
interest is federal regulations and
prescribes a proactive approach whereby
state regulatory agencies will
collaborate to address Federal
concerns in summary the new policy keeps
most of the Declarations of the old
policy but prescribes Market oriented
solution and limits government
intervention press the green button to
send this important policy update to the
other body for a second time thank you
Mr
Speaker representative Osborne has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of a passes amended on
House Bill 504 this is a roll call vote
chair recognized representative Kaplan
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that the current state energy
policy and this proposed energy policy
share a similar first line calling for
Reliable cost effective safe and diverse
energy sources but Mr Speaker if I know
that this proposed policy adds a second
line calling for a specific type of
energy resource which makes the first
line meaningless because you can't have
diverse energy resources while you're
calling for a specific type of energy
resource Mr Speaker if I know that this
new policy also has a third line which
calls for us to enhance so-called our
state's energy Independence which is not
a thing because we are part of a
regional new england-wide electricity
grid which benefits us with safe
reliable cost effective and diverse
energy resources for our
people Mr Speaker would I not then
choose the official state energy policy
which is concise reasonable and well
balanced and therefore useful over this
new policy which is rambling internally
contradictory and at times meaningless
by a simple push on the red button Mr
Speaker would I not then do that yes I
would so should
you do J recognize representative votes
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that without Dependable
energy our economy would falter and fail
to
thrive knowing this would I now press
the green button to support an emphasis
on Dependable energy in New Hampshire
thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us maor
committee report of Auto pass as amended
on House Bill 504 this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppose you'll
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
vote you wondering for voting a 165
adopted committee on science technology
and energy to which was referred House
Bill 508 FN relative to decreasing
assessment rates for entities providing
voi p and IP enabled Services as well as
certain local exchange carriers and
their Affiliates consider the same
report the same with a following
recommendation the bill ought to pass
committee bill is on second reading open
to further Amendment and representative
Harrington offers floor Amendment
0269 H printed in house Record 12 page
39 and representative Harrington's
recognized speak to his uh motion thank
you Mr Speaker this is going to be the
easiest vote of the day so relax I'm not
going to be here very long the amendment
is simply to create correct the typo in
the bill there was two places where the
number was supposed to be changed from
33% to 10% we missed one I apologize
that corrects that so please vote in
favor of the amendment the main Bill
simply corrects a mistake that's been
going on for a number of years we almost
completely deregulated landline
telephones but we kept charging them the
same fee for regulation that they had in
the past so there no sense in charging
someone for regulation when they're not
getting regulated that bill corrects the
problem so please vote in favor of the
amendment and then the vote vote for the
bill as Amendment thank
you the motion before us is the
Harington floor Amendment 0269 H are you
ready for the question on the amendment
all those in favor say i i suppos n the
eyes have it amendment is adopted the
motion before us now is a to pass as
amended House Bill 508 FN are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I I I oppose nay the eyes have it and
amended majority committee on science
technology and energy to which was
referred House Bill 682 act relative to
the office of offshore wind industry the
offshore and the port development
commission and the office of energy
Innovation having considered the same
report the same with the recommendation
the bill ought to pass sen James Summers
from the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate Senator Wendy
Thomas from the minority of the
committee chair recognizes
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker house
bills 682 removes us from the table of
any discussion about offshore wind you
know when I was in Greece I saw many W
wind turbines on the tops of virtually
every mountain
range how did you get the people to
accept wind power I asked our guide he
looked at me like I was nuts we respect
our people and we respect our land it's
free energy why wouldn't we use wind
power why wouldn't we
indeed we hear a lot of energy bills in
our committee and many times that old
and clearly debatable axium comes up
quote let the free market take care of
it however in order for a free market to
be free it actually needs to be free one
cannot not support the idea of a free
market on one hand throttling an
Innovative Market on the other hand just
because you don't understand it or
because it can't be monetized in the
same way that fossil fuels
can you either believe in a free market
or you
don't and while the market is not
favorable to Offshore wind right now it
is expensive technology changes are
being made on an almost daily basis
improvements that will enhance
performance and lower costs will be
coming down the road removing us from
this discussion is to put and keep New
Hampshire's head into its very Rocky
sand also let us not forget that wind
power offers an economic stimulus for
New Hampshire new industry with good
clean energy jobs would be available to
our Workforce something that is
desperately needed in our
state New Hampshire's en energy strategy
is one of all of the above it's a set of
policies that support oil and natural
gas and simultaneously every other form
of domestic energy including solar wind
geothermal and
nuclear removing winds circumvents are
agreed upon energy policy and
unnecessarily restricts what we can use
now or in the future this bill hobbles
Us in the majority report the
environment was raised
look not only am I considered a tree
hugger but I am old enough to have to
have had a save the whales bumper
sticker on my VW Beetle in high
school I am very concerned about the
environment I live in a town where an
industrial polluter has poisoned our
environment I fight for accountability
every day but let's look at the bigger
picture the Gulf of Maine has already
heated up in fact it has warmed faster
than 99% of the global
Ocean warmer water res results in
ecological
change just like we are seeing tropical
storms in the Gulf of Mexico become cat
for hurricanes in 24 hours excuse me I'm
talking how will be in
order so are we seeing changes in all
large bodies of water like the Gulf of
Maine the weather is changing as is the
fish
population for example lobsters are
becoming more suceptible to Shell
disease and predatory fish because of
War uh predatory fish because of warm
water warming waters are also causing
lobsters to migrate North and farther
offshore to Waters that are
colder now let's talk about those whales
that were mentioned in the majority
report there are ongoing fabricated
stories about whales being harmed by
wind power we hear it all the time it's
kind of like that urban legend about
that kid who died from eating Pop
Rocks however according to Noah which is
the National Oceanic and Atmospheric ad
Administration which is peer-reviewed by
the way quote at this point there is no
scientific evidence that noise resulting
from offshore wind sight
characterization surveys could
potentially cause wh whale deaths there
is no known links between large whale
deaths and ongoing offshore wind
activities and here's the thing if you
are truly concerned about whales then
you would do something about climate
change the rapid warming of the planet
is leading to a loss of habitat for
whales and greater competition for a
diminishing amount of prey
species it is affecting the timing and
ranges of their migration their
distribution and even their ability to
reproduce climate change and our
reliance on fossil fuels is only going
to accelerate those
changes so yes although I no longer have
my VW I still believe that we need to
save the whales but it is not through
stopping wind power it will be through
stopping our Reliance on fossil
fuels finally let's talk about that
executive order that was mentioned in
the majority report that eliminates
offshore
wind to date the current Administration
has signed over 65 executive orders many
of which are currently being legally
challenged with allegations that those
orders are
unconstitutional exceed presidential
Authority and infringe upon the first
and Fifth Amendment
rights I'm not sure me the member will
if a member is requesting a point of
order they have to come down the member
is requesting a point of order they have
to come down to the podium
State what their point of order is and
is members recognize for point of order
thank you Mr Speaker so this is my first
time being up here so just give you know
your point State your point of order
point of order is this has nothing to do
with the
order
well we we unfortunately I don't know
what every bill says so I can't say it
is or it isn't has to do with something
with the
bill member may continue thank you thank
you Mr Speaker as I was saying I'm not
sure referencing a current
administrative EO right now is the flex
that you think it is bottom line when it
comes to Offshore wind power New
Hampshire should be at the table we
don't have it now but we will have it
someday it's coming keeping us in the
wind power discussion is an investment
for New Hampshire's Energy Future and it
is a true example of a free market for
these reasons I ask you to oppose the
motion of OTP so that a more
energy-friendly and job promoting motion
request I request a roll call please
thank
you chair recognize your OBS some sit
down he has he has not asked not I
yet chair recognize don't do that chair
recognize representative Summers I'll
debate thank you thank you Mr Speaker
and thank thank you for your leadership
after analyzing the European leadership
I thank God every day of our freedom of
speech we have here in
America Mr Speaker HP 682 would remove
the offshore wind industry development
from the office of energy Innovation it
would repeal the offshore wind industry
Workforce Training Center committee and
the offshore and Port development
commission and moves the grid
modernization advisory Council and the
hydrogen advisory Council to the office
of energy
Innovation after president Trump's
executive order to eliminate offshore
wind and turbans the committee's
received experien expert peer-reviewed
research and testimony from the
Fisheries associations on the
chlorination and chemicals added to the
ocean water by offshore wind
transmission cables along with
information removing the Plankton from
the surface destroying local sea life
and the sea life cycle electromagnetic
fields caused by as small as fiber optic
cables in the ocean can reroute sharks
and Rays disrupting offshore Fisheries
never mind the electromagnetic field
created by the transmission lines from
offshore wind
turbines Mr Speaker who would have
thought the day would come when the left
would hold the religion of climate
change with higher preceden than
Greenpeace the fact is that offshore
wind is more expensive and destructive
than any other renewable energy source
press the green button for the
Automotion aop pass motion for this
crucial
Bill representative Thomas has requested
a roll call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
the motion before is the majority
committee report of Auto pass on House
Bill 682 this is a roll call vote chair
recognized representative Corman for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that the market-based approach
to energy that we Embrace does not
currently favor offshore wind
but if I also know that technology
changes so that market conditions May
someday be favorable to Offshore wind
then Mr Speaker would I press the red
button to not prematurely lock out New
Hampshire from the potential benefits of
offshore
wind chair recognize representa Bernardi
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
offshore wind is not free market but is
wholly government
subsidized and if I know the
reorganization of the office of energy
Innovation will bring efficiency and
focus to important and emerging emerging
energy programs would I push the green
button motion motion before us is
majority committee report of a to pass
on House Bill 682 this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppos to press
the red button voting stations are open
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
vote 206 voting yay 163 voting a the
adopted for what reason does the member
rise uh thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
I would move that the debate regarding
offshore wind in the Gulf of New
Hampshire be entered into the permanent
objection committee on transportation to
which was referred House Bill 260 FN in
act creating a commemorative license
plate celebrating the 250th anniversary
of Bunker Hill consider the same report
the same with the following Amendment
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with Amendment presentive Daniel
Vu for the committee the amendment is 0
139h printed in house Record 12 page 36
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
oppose nay the eyes have it amendment is
adopted the motion before us now is
ought to pass with Amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I call Nay the eyes have it
adopted committee on transportation to
which was referred House Bill
287a an act requiring police departments
to provide fire departments with certain
motorist personnel and insurance
information following a motor vehical
incident having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution that the that is inexpedient
to legislate representative Ted Gorski
for the committee are you ready for the
question all those in favor say
nay chair is in doubt on that we will
have a clarifying vote members take your
out this is a clarifying vote on the
motion of inexpedient to legislate if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you oppose you'll press a red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
represent
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state of
okay the magic of
Technology the vote being 2011 y 163 a
adopted majority committee on
transportation to which was referred
House Bill
368 an act prohibiting smoking and e
cigarettes and Motor Vehicles when a
passenger is under 16 years of age
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate representative Matthew Peto
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same been unable to agree
with the majority Report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative Daniel V for the
minority of the committee the chair
thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I I if I know uh I
would like to speak about about HB 368 a
measure that focuses on a shared
priority protecting the health of our
children we talk about secondhand smoke
we're not dealing with when we talk
about secondhand smoke we're not dealing
with speculation or Theory the science
is clear the risks are real we know that
cigarette smoke contains over 7,000
chemicals hundreds of which are toxic
and at least 70 known carcinogen
carcinogens we know that when an adult
smokes in a confined space like a car
the levels of dangerous pollutants can
go be up to 10 times higher than in a
home we know that a child's lungs still
developing and more vulnerable absorb
these chemicals at a higher rate
exposure to secondhand smoke has been
directly linked to higher rates of
asthma and chronic respiratory
infections in children increased risk of
sudden infant death syndrome long-term
effects including reduced lung function
and greater susceptibility to disease
later in life but this is not just about
traditional cigarettes ecigarettes or
vaping devices are also expose children
to Har harmful substances researchers
found that Vape arisol is not just
harmless water vapor it contains
nicotine fine metal particles and
volatile organic compounds that damage
lung tissue while adults make informed
decisions about what they choose to
inhale a children in the the backseat of
a car has no choice at
all some might say this bill isn't
needed that parents will make
responsible choices on their own and
many do but pediatricians Public Health
experts and Decades of research tell us
that this remains a persistent health
issue a child trapped in a smoke filed
car has no Escape rolling down a window
does not eliminate exposure studies show
that toxins still circulate and settle
in the confined
space this bill simply ures that when
children are inside a vehicle they are
not subjected to something we know is
harmful
preventable and completely within our
power to
stop HP 368 does not restrict adults
from smoking or vaping in their daily
lives it does not apply in homes or
other private spaces it's simply a
targeted sensible measure to prevent
children from being involuntarily
exposed to toxic air in an enclosed
environment where they have no control
this is not about politics it's not
about personal freedoms it's about
protecting the most vulnerable Among Us
from an entirely preventable health risk
I urge you to support this bill not
because it regulates but because it
safeguards not because it limits but
because it Shields children from
harm that could affect them for the rest
of their lives thank you here recognize
representative
Gori thank you Mr Speaker speaker Mr
Speaker I stand in support of the
committee report of itl of HP
368 and I do this for two main reasons
number one the flawed premise of the
bill the main premise of this bill is to
eliminate smoking in ecigarettes when a
passenger is under the age of
16 however if someone does smoke with a
passenger under the age of 16 it is only
enforcable under a secondary
offense so if a driver
decides to obey the rules of the road he
or
she can have a passenger under the age
of 16 and can smoke to their hearts
content it defeats the whole premise of
the
bill secondly it invades a car owner's
civil
liberties if this bill is passed it
allows the government to tell someone
what they can or cannot do in their
vehicle what What's Next Car Radio is
too loud and it hurts their ears maybe
you can't drink coffee because it's hot
and will spill on your
lap the bill is a slippery slope with
that I ask you to press the green button
and tell the government to stay out of
our vehicle thank you Mr
Speaker house will be in
order representative Granger has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
the motion before us is inexpedient the
majority committee report of inexpedient
legislate on House Bill 368 this is a
roll call all vote chair recognized
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker colleagues if I know that every
child deserves the right to a safe and
healthy
environment and if I also know that
secondhand smoke is a proven Hazard not
only to everyone's Health but
particularly to Children's Health and
finally if I know that a child is often
required to ride in a vehicle where the
adults are at smoking and they have no
choice but to do so would I now vote no
on the pending itl motion so that
another motion can be
introduced chair recognize
inquiring thank you Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker if I know that this bill if pass
will infringe on the civil liberties of
smokers and drivers and if I know that
the premise of this bill is flawed then
would I press the green button to
support the itl motion thank you the
motion before us is the majority
committee report of any Meed to
legislator on House Bill 368 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're oppos
you'll press the red button voting
[Music]
up before I announce the vote the next
two votes are going to be division votes
with pis only so if everybody stays in
your seat we can get through it pretty
quickly if all those president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
stay to the
vote 213 voting yay 157 voting 80
majority of the committee on ways and
means to which was referred House Bill
255 FN an act increasing the percentage
of Revenue deposited in the education
trust fund from the business profits tax
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate s Julius suty
for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following recommendation that the
bill ought to pass from Tom M shamberg
for the minority of the committee this
vote members members take your seats
motion before it say the majority
committee report of vped to legisl on
House Bill 255 this a division vote the
chair Recon as representative shamberg
inquir thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that changing the percentage of the
business profits tax per section
77820 that is deposited in the education
trust fund from 41% to
59% would add an estimated $158 million
for public education student aid and if
I know that this percentage change would
not increase the business profits tax
rate but would provide for property tax
relief by increas in funding for public
education Mr Speaker would I now push
the red button so that another motion
could be
made chair recog nightes representative
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill would not raise
any Revenue but instead would just move
money from the business profits tax to
the more money to the education trust
fund and substantially less money to the
general fund and if I know that this
would then create an underfunding issue
in the general fund would I now press
the green button to itl this bill the
motion before is majority committee
report of inexpedient to legislative
House Bill 255 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppos you'll
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
representative
Stone representative
[Music]
Stone well remember is president had
opportunity to vote house attend to stay
the
vote 341 voting a 29 voting a committee
adopted majority of the committee on
ways and means to which was referred
House Bill 318 FN an act relative to the
percentage of revenue from the business
Enterprise tax deposit in the education
trust fund considered the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolved that is inex to legislate
Julius so for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the recommendation to Bill a a pass
representive Thomas shanberg the
minority of the committee this is going
clear the motion before us a majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legisla and House Bill 318 this a
division vote shair recognized represent
ingree thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that changing the percentage
amount of the business Enterprise tax
per section 77 e14 from 41% to 59% would
add an estimated $68 million to the educ
tion trust fund and if I know that this
43.9% increase would provide an option
for the legislature to address adequate
funding issues for public education and
property tax relief would I now push the
red button so that another motion could
be made chair recognize representative
Jian for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill is very similar
to the last one and that a 16 to4
bipartisan vote of the committee uh
thought this bill should be ited then
when I pressed the green button to itl
this bill the motion before is a
majority committee report of inexpedient
to legisla and House Bill 318 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're oppos
you'll press a red button voting
[Music]
V president I had an opportunity to vote
340 voting a 28 voting a committee
adopted majority committee on ways and
means to which was referred House Bill
502 FN act relative to complete
corporate reporting for unitary
businesses under the business profits
tax having revenues from the state
education property tax having considered
the same Report with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to leg
representative Jordan YY for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass representative Thomas Opel for
the minority of the committee chair
Opel thank you Mr
Speaker The Waters Edge method of
business taxation in New Hampshire was
adopted for the benefit of foreign
businesses that's not my words those are
the words of a decision from the New
Hampshire Supreme
Court The Waters Edge provision permits
foreign multinationals to Shield
activities outside of the United States
using legal paper transactions to shift
profits and tax liability from the US to
lower tax
jurisdictions the Hampshire companies
whether they directly compete with these
multinationals or not pay their full
business tax
liability while multinationals can evade
some or even all of their tax
liability the Hampshire now cannot
accurately determine the scope of profit
shifting but even supporters of this
unfair tax scheme acknowledge profit
shifting still
occurs sound tax policy our state and
federal
constitutions and the rule of law all
dictate equal treatment which is exactly
what hp2 FN complete corporate reporting
would
achieve with complete corporate
reporting all companies whether based in
Manchester New Hampshire or Manchester
England would report all of their
activities across the
globe the New Hampshire tax liability
could then be precisely determined by
comparing Granite State activity to
Global activity finally leveling the
competitive playing field for all
businesses operating in the
hire and while estimates differ every
estimate is predicting additional
Revenue with this change for our state
and we believe those additional dollars
could go to property tax relief by
providing additional support for public
schools this bill does not impose a new
tax it simply makes foreign
multinationals subject to the same rules
as every other Enterprise doing business
in the granite
state now you may hear all sorts of
complicated arguments against what is
basically a simple
idea you may hear that no other state
relies on complete corporate reporting
also known as worldwide combined
reporting but in fact several states do
employ versions of it some may worry
that no Hampshire will be the first to
truly adopt complete corporate reporting
but this is the first in the nation
presidential primary State and this was
the first state to adopt a Statewide
Lottery the majority report says the
commission that studied this issue
rejected it 7 to1 but I would point out
in that report three
members explicitly said they were not
taking a position on that
issue fundamentally the opposition boils
down to this
change is too
hard but the fact is it's not complete
corporate reporting is not even new it
was the law in New Hampshire until the
middle
1980s so colleagues I ask you to please
push the red button to defeat the
majority recommendation so we can move
on to support complete corporate
reporting and finally level the playing
field for business in the granite state
it's just this simple do you stand with
the Hampshire businesses or do you stand
with foreign
multinationals and Mr Speaker I ask for
a roll call vote thank you chair
bilbury thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker HB 502 represents an
effort to revive an obscure business tax
methodology that New Hampshire adopted
Ed in 1981 and repealed by
1986 in a nationwide wave of rejection
enjoying an ultra short lifespan 40
years ago HB 502 would require any
multinational entity as a condition of
doing business in New Hampshire to
declare all of its worldwide income no
matter where earned to the New Hampshire
Department of Revenue and then apply
apportionment formulas to determine how
much of of it is attributable to New
Hampshire an essentially identical
proposition was the subject of a
2022-23 statutory commission which I
chaired and uh that commission
recommended 7 to one against adop reopt
no worldwide combined reporting this
body rejected a similar bill just last
year since the federal government
mandates separate entity reporting with
so-called arms length adjust ments HB
502 would require a magnitude greater
information to be filed in New Hampshire
over what the
IRS or any other state requires creating
a significant disincentive to doing
business in New
Hampshire this would be particularly Odd
as the takeoff point for a fi for filing
a business tax return in New Hampshire
is the net uh taxable income on the
federal return thus a multinational
business filing in New Hampshire would
have to deal with an array of
disclosures and hurdles to modify or
adjust net Federal taxable
income the Bill's sponsors seem to be
under the delusion that this is a simple
straightforward matter of adding up
their known and declared earnings
obtained in every other
country but net taxable incomes as
declared in other countries may have
little relationship to
ours as countries vary greatly in their
accounting conventions reporting
requirements tax schemes and rules not
to mention languages and currencies
compliance with New Hampshire's
requirements would demand enormous time
and effort to adjust for Conformity with
rules regarding what is taxable as well
as what deductions disallowances or
credits may be
allowable a new burden would also fall
onto the Dr staff requiring in their
words quote more of everything close
quote more forms reviews audits travel
and
enforcement the sponsors presume that
this requirement will inevitably bring
greater business tax revenue to New
Hampshire's coffers but in fact it's not
obvious that it will increase New
Hampshire revenues some filers will owe
more some will owe less according to how
they did elsewhere in the world so there
will be winners and losers amongst tax
filers and those that are losers this
Year may be winners next year and nobody
can guess whether New Hampshire's
business revenues will be the winner in
any given year determining a business's
liability for tax on profits earned in
New Hampshire by measuring it everywhere
else is a convoluted approach that would
not provide the benefits the sponsors
imagin and might even result in reduced
Revenue in New Hampshire all while
alienating multinational organizations
both us based and foreign based from
doing business here please vote and
supported the itl motion on HB 502 thank
you representative Opel has requested a
roll call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
clear the motion before us majority
committee report of any expedient to
legislator and House Bill 502 this is a
roll call vote chair recognize
representative shanberg for a
parliamentary
inquiry Mr Speaker if I know that the
current Waters Edge allows companies to
shift profits and evade tax liability
and if I know that making foreign
multinationals pay their fair share
equals property tax relief and money for
New Hampshire and finally Mr Speaker if
I know that there is no added tax burden
for New Hampshire us companies would I
push the red button to present another
motion chair recognize representative R
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
this bill is based on a fail over
taxation policy that it cost money to
implement that it reduces revenue and it
encourages businesses to leave New
Hampshire would I push the green I
button major the motion before us
majority committee report of inexpedient
to legisla on House Bill 502 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you press the red button voting stations
[Music]
Schmidt all members present have an
opportunity to vote also attend to stay
of the
vote 209 voting a 163 voting 8 committee
majority committee on children and
family law to which was referred house
buillt 243 FN act relative to the
penalty for the false reports of
suspected abuse and neglect made to the
division of children youth and families
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate sen representa Peter pataro
from the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with a recommendation that the bill
ought to pass representative Janie
Nelson for the minority of the committee
Speaker child abuse is one of the most
heartbreaking issues in our society it's
a reality that no child should ever have
to endure and we have a responsibility
to protect vulnerable vulnerable
children from harm but as much as we
need to focus on preventing real abuse
and ensuring children's safety we also
must address the serious problem of
false reporting the consequences of
false reporting are profound false
accusations can destroy lives damage
reputations and undermine the very
systems designed to protect children
when false reports are made valuable
resources are diverted away from those
who truly need help and create
unnecessary Panic distrust and confusion
House Bill 243 establishes civil and
criminal liability consequences for
those who who would make malicious false
reports in order to weaponize the system
anyone participating in good faith in
the making of a report or who provides
information or assistance pursuant to a
good faith report of child abuse or
neglect is immune from any liability
civil or
criminal various studies and experts
estimate that between 30 and 50% of
child abuse claims in high conflict
custody cases may be false the parent
who is the target of false accusations
could lose custody or visitation rights
with their child being falsely accused
of abuse can affect their employment and
social relationships put an immense
strain on their finances in in extreme
cases they could face criminal
prosecution resulting in jail time most
disturbing is that the damaging effects
of false allegations on children can
that can last a lifetime potentially
each time a report is filed the child
may have to undergo unnecessary and
sometimes very intrusive medical exams
physical evaluations may be performed
and the child May undergo repeated
questioning by case workers therapists
police investigators and child Advocates
child care providers and daycare centers
are also targets of false reporting from
disgruntled former employees and
sometimes former clients an
investigation into the alleged abuse can
bring severe legal and financial
consequences for the child care provider
the child care provider may be suspended
from their job or the center temporarily
closed while the investigation is
conducted child care providers rely
heavily on the reputation and Trust
within the community to continue their
work false accusations can severely
damage this trust the immediate
suspension or termination of the
provider from their position can lead to
disruption in the care of the children
this disruption can create emotional
instability and confusion for children
and can have a significant negative
impact on the parents if as they have to
find Alternative Care or Miss days of
work resulting in loss wages or putting
their employment in
Jeopardy I actually have had experience
with this nightmare so I know all of the
above to be true one one evening I
received a phone call telling me that
our home daycare was being investigated
for child abuse this woman had lovingly
cared for three children in our extended
family over the years and I was shocked
I told the case worker that I was sure
there has to has to be a mistake that
our Sharon was a wonderful mother and
her younger youngest son was 17 years
old I was confused the worker next said
no Mrs Nelson she is accused of abusing
children and her home daycare including
your daughter and you will have to
immediately find Alternative Care until
our invest investigation is
completed well the case was investigated
and closed in a timely manner a new
neighbor who didn't like the sound of
children playing next door
filed a false report in the hopes that
the children would go away as a result
of their
accusation saying that was an extremely
difficult time is an
understatement the US Department of
Health and Human Services states that
studies estimate that approximately 1%
to 8% of all reports to CPS are
malicious or false so if we meet
somewhere in the middle and use 4% that
means that potentially there are 800
malicious reports a year here in New
Hampshire that divert resources from
legitimate cases where children are
truly at risk that that overburden
social workers who may be forced to
follow through with extensive
investigations this takes time and can
lead to delays in investigating real
child welfare cases false reporting can
also result in court cases which require
time and money if a false report leads
to legal proceedings this can waste
public resources and further B burden
our Judicial System the majority of US
states have penalties for malicious
reporting of child abuse in Florida
making a false report is classified as a
third degree felony which can result in
penalties including fines and up to 5
years in prison in Michigan penalties
for false reporting may include
significant fines and imprisonment
particularly if the report results in
harm to the person being falsely accused
in California the laws for the law
allows for a fine of up to $1,000 in
potential jail time for individuals to
file a false report with the intention
of causing harm or
disruption we heard in testimony that
implementing these penalties will
prevent callers from wanting to report
actual abuse when asked for data from
other states that have implemented
penalties showing uh
sorry when asked for data from other
states that have implemented penalties
showing a decrease in reporting that
information couldn't be provided to the
committee since no state that that has
implemented laws regarding false
reporting has repealed those laws I
think that's proof that that's not a
problem and speaking of California
governor Newsome signed a bill into law
that became effective last month to
further efforts to cut down on false
reports states are making more laws
regarding this not less lastly even
though our committee does great
bipartisan work there are a few bills
that we disc agree on and obviously this
is one of
them interestingly in many other states
there's a bipartisan effort to clamp
down on false
reporting like California Utah and New
York please join these states and others
to protect innocent individuals families
and businesses and make sure that every
child's well-being remains a priority
and press the red button so another
patrio thank you Mr
Speaker this legislation has very good
intentions it seeks to prevent false and
malicious reports about child abuse and
neglect of
DCF however there are two big
problems first those who seek to make
such reports May continue to be
anonymous with the call center never
knowing who who actually made the false
report in the first
place secondly and more
importantly the call center May inform
the caller that false reports may bring
about civil and criminal penalties that
alone may be enough to make good faith
repor is hesitant second guessing
themselves and not file a legitimate
report putting a child at risk and if
one child is put at risk that's one
child too many so while the bill has
good intentions it's impractical and
potentially harmful so I urge you to
vote with the majority of the children
and family law committee where we put
the safety and the welfare of Children
First above all else and I ask you to
vote itl Mr Speaker I request a division
much division a division has been
the motion before us majority commit a
report of inexpedient to legislate on
House Bill 243 this is a division vote
the chair recognizes representative D
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this will not prevent
anybody from calling
anonymously but it will allow the intake
people to recognize voices and phone
if I also know that according to the
parents rights Foundation National
statistics 83% of child abuse and
neglect cases are
false reports in states with penalties
or false reports it is 96% in the states
where there is no penalty against false
reporters the difference of 2600
calls or report courts that could delay
saving a true
victim where there were about 20,000
calls made to dcyf right here in New
Hampshire
10,000 are weeded out and less than a
thousand actually go to
court the concern May if I know that one
concern is the fear of good callers will
avoid calling I think I debunked that in
my
first finally Mr Speaker if I know that
false reports harm not only the parents
but more the children and that's a
concern of DCF and children and family
law that I have heard time and time and
time again in my 17 years of serving so
Mr Speaker I ask that everybody vote red
soone I'll alternative motion can be
brought thank you Mr
Speaker chair recognized representative
un thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
understand that other states that have
successfully enacted such um legislation
do not have Anonymous reporting and if I
also understand that if I was doing
something for nefarious purposes I would
certainly not be giving my name and if I
further understand that this bill does
not compel nor mandate someone to give
their name rendering this an
unsuccessful way to handle this would I
not press the green to agree with the
majority of the bipartisan committee
thank
you the motion we force majority
committer report of inexpedient to
legisl on House Bill 243 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button of your opposer
press the red button voting stations are
she
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
vote 165 voting a 205 voting a the
motion
fails representative Nelson moves ought
to
pass are you ready for the question all
those in favor say
iose
nay the eyes have it and the motion of
adopted the bill is being referred to
majority committee on criminal justice
and Public Safety to which was referred
House Bill 56 FN act requiring a
background check and mandatory waiting
period during certain firearm transfers
consider the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate sen of J
Rose for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass sen of David Muse for the
minority of the committee the chair
Muse thank you Mr
Speaker in this body most of us aren't
shy when it comes to using our
legislative Authority to support victims
while we may have our differences
victims of violent crime and domestic
abuse have many friends in this
legislature but there are two sets of
victims that far too many of us prefer
not to think about or not to see these
are the victims of gun violence and
Firearm suicide in our
state today I come before you to ask for
your help and passing a common sense
Public Safety bill that would change
this by doing two things first first
hp56 at long last would Implement a
universal firearms background check
process for our state and secondly it
would establish a minimum 72-hour
waiting period before a Firearms
transfer can take
place the bill has two main goals the
first is to reduce the risk of firearms
from falling into the hands of felons
protective order violators domestic
abusers and people whose severe mental
illness makes them fed ineligible to
purchase
firearms the second goal is to help
reduce gun homicides and suicides in our
state by creating a 72-hour buffer of
time that can help people who are in
crisis or who are considering suicide or
an impulsive act of
violence currently in New Hampshire a
firearms background check is only
required when a Firearms purchase is
made from a federally licensed dealer
while it's a felony in New hampsh ampure
to sell or transfer a firearm to a
convicted felon enforcing this
prohibition is a challenge because of a
critical loophole in our state we don't
require background checks for Private
Sales that don't involve a licensed
dealer this loophole creates a dangerous
loophole in our law it not only makes it
easier for a convicted felon to to
obtain a firearm but it also makes it
easier for domestic abusers and other
people that our laws have already
determined pose a public safety risk
high enough to prohibit them from owning
a
firearm under the bill transfers between
private parties will be facilitated by a
federally licensed firearm dealer at
their place of business the role of the
dealer will be to initiate the
background process background check
process to notify the parties of the
result and if the background check
clears to complete the transfer between
the two parties unlike past attempts to
pass a bill like this this bill does not
try to parse the difference between a
commercial sale and a private sale with
a handful of sensible objections this
bill simply requires a background check
facilitated by a federally Firearms uh
by a federally licensed Firearms dealer
for the transfer of ownership of a
firearm where neither party is a
licensed Firearms
dealer also in response to feedback from
gun owners this Bill does carve out
sensible OB uh exemptions for certain
types of transfers among them are gifts
and inheritances between immediate
family members as well as temporary
transfers between hunters and Target
Shooters who simply want to try out
another Shooters weapon another key part
of the bill is a minimum 72-hour waiting
period between the time a background
check is initiated and the transfer of
the firearm to the new owner currently
there is no waiting period period and a
weapon can be transferred as soon as a
background check clears under this bill
the waiting period would start
immediately after the initiation of the
background check by the dealer if the
background check clears the waiting
period would expire after 72 hours after
the process was first initiated by the
dealer to be clear no transfer could
take place until the background check
clears even if it takes more than 72
hours for people in crisis a brief
mandatory waiting period can mean the
difference between life and death during
the public hearing we H we heard from a
hookset mother who lost her 21-year-old
son to Suicide with a firearm he had
just
purchased we also heard testimony from
the New Hampshire Psychiatric Society
that suicide attempts are often
impulsive singular tragedies that
because of the damage a bullet can do a
suicide attempt with a firearm is often
90%
successful while there are admittedly
other ways you can take your own life a
suicide attempt with a firearm is almost
always fatal waiting periods can give
people additional time they need to get
help or to think through their
actions Donna Moren the mom who
testified before our committee told us
that a waiting period period may have
very well saved her son's life in a
similar way Studies have also shown that
the kind of short-lived anger and rage
that might lead a person to purchase a
weapon to harm another person can
actually dissipate over a fairly short
period of
time waiting periods provide a cooling
off period for people who might harm
themselves or who might harm others
Universal background checks can help
reduce the risk of firearms from falling
into the hands of people that are laws
for very good reason already prohibit
from purchasing or possessing firearms
so Mr Speaker for these reasons I urge
you to vote against the itl M motion so
rhods thank you Mr
Speaker I know many of you might be
thinking it seems like we're going to
hear a lot of the bills again today
they've been all resurrected and you're
right but this one is different I'm
going to tell you
why we keep on hearing that this is
about suicide prevention but when asked
in the committee about a woman that
maybe is the victim of domestic violence
why would there not be an exception for
her if she wanted to go purchase a
firearm because that exception was in
their last year we were told Well
because most likely she's not trained
and doesn't know how to use the firearm
properly I'm certain that we don't have
a law that says you have to be trained
we probably should be careful cuz that
will be next but we'll kill that one too
Mr Speaker don't
worry we also heard that there's not an
exception for anybody that might be a
hunter or somebody that might already
own one firearm or 100 Firearms so not
really sure the reason for the waiting
period especially waiting 72 hours after
your criminal background check has
already come back
we keep on being told this is about
suicide
prevention but the very people that are
bringing this bill telling us this is
about suicide prevention are voting for
an assisted suicide Bill make that make
sense it seems to me if this was really
about suicide
prevention we would have the reasonable
exceptions that should be in here even
though those were killed I I I'll be it
those were killed last year as well but
it seems given all the talk about one
thing but nothing that actually shows
that what's it about I would have to say
control represent of grer has requested
a roll call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of in expedient to
legislated on House Bill 56 this is a
roll call vote chair recognizes
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that keeping deadly weapons out of the
hands of more felons and domestic
abusers is one of the most meaningful
things we can do to protect Public
Safety and if I know that a short
cooling off period between the time a
weapon is purchased and the time a new
owner takes delivery will save lives and
if I know that while there are many
things from housing to child care to
Mental Health Services that our state
could use more of two things we
absolutely could use less of are victims
of gun violence and victims of gun
suicide then would I press the red
button so another motion may be made
thank you chair recognize representative
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that saying one thing but
reading the words on the piece of paper
say two different stories and if I know
that Maine has just overturned their
72-hour waiting
period And if I know that there really
is no reason to pass this bill what I
just now press green with the committee
thank you the motion before us majority
commit a report of inexpedient to
legislator House Bill 56 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're oppos
you'll press the red button voting
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
vote 216 voting a 154 voting a report is
adopted
Sweeney for a lunch announcement thank
you Mr Speaker uh all legislators are
cordially invited to the first inaugural
New Hampshire Life Sciences legislative
lunch taking place in the State House
cafeteria right in the basement uh
please gather it's a new Association for
the life science Industry in the state
wait wait a minute everybody please take
their seat we haven't finished
yet for what reason does a member
rise Mr Speaker I Rise to ask that the
remarks on House Bill 368 be printed in
the permanent
journal without
objection and I recognize the clerk Mr
Speaker pursuant to house rule 47f uh
the chair of criminal justice has waved
the second committee refer ref of house
1:00
e
has referred House Bill 75 FN act
legalizing cannabis for person 21 years
of age or older having considered the
same report the same with a fallen
resolution resolve that is inexpedient
to legislate presentative Jennifer rhods
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with a
recommendation to Bill AO pass alisandra
representative alisandra Marie from the
minority of the committee the chair
newel thank you Mr
Speaker I rise today as I have before to
speak speak on behalf of the
overwhelming majority of granite Staters
who implore this body to end the
criminalization of cannabis to end the
fear of unnecessary disruption to
people's lives in the event that they
find Cannabis to be their nighttime
sleep aid their mood
enhancer um or their morning pickme
up I stand before you as a person who
has been humbled by life circumstances
not the least of which is the tragic
loss of my fiance to heroin
overdose but also my big brother and my
best friend in the whole world to
alcoholism these substances kill our
loved
ones yet the latter is perfectly legal
We Trust our citizens over the age of 21
to consume alcohol responsibly and
rightly so but somehow we still maintain
that our citizens cannot be trusted to
consume cannabis
responsibly even as we know that it is
virtually impossible to consume a lethal
amount and even as we know that cannabis
is a much safer alternative to the
substances that have taken the lives of
my loved ones and likely many of
yours so here I stand asking you once
again to pass legislation that would
entrust our citizens over the age of 21
with the resp responsibility to consume
cannabis if they so choose without fear
of Retribution from the state and who
knows we may just save some lives while
Roy thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if
we decide to legalize marijuana then we
should do it correctly um in an orderly
way I mean I know we've tried in 50
different bills over the last few years
nothing seems to go through and let me
tell you this one ain't going to go
through either we know it's not going to
get all the way through so let's do it
smart and do something that takes care
of children and has guard rails and
protections not just throw it out there
if we're going to do it do it right no
state that have done it so far has just
thrown it open and said here you go
there's guard rails we need to at least
have some guard rails and while I
understand the theem motion of trying to
get something through and it can't seem
to go through the answer is not to just
throw something out there and hope it
passes if we do it it's got to be done
responsibly our constituents expect it
to be done responsibly not just for us
to throw up our hands and say fine
everybody have some part so vote your
conscience I just think that we need to
be a little bit more
careful representative Granger has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficient ly seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
where the motion before is a majority
commit a report of inexpedient to
legislate and House
75 chair recognizes alisandra Murray for
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that Granite Staters have
asked us again and again to legalize
cannabis in the state and if I know that
previous attempts to legalize
recreational Cannabis have been too
complicated to get full approval of this
body but this bill did pass unanimous or
not unanimously but pass by a majority
of this house last year and if I further
know that cannabis is easily accessible
in every single state around us and
therefore impossible for us to prevent
its presence in our communities and Mr
Speaker if I know this means we are
arresting and criminalizing our
constituents unjustly for participating
in activities that should be legal would
I now press the red button to defeat the
itl so a better motion can be made thank
you chair recognize representative Roy
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that if we're going to do
something we should do it right and Mr
Speaker if I know that the way to do it
right is not just to throw it open and
say figure it out for yourselves to our
constituents would I then vote to uphold
the itl and actually take the time and
put in the bill and do the research and
do it right thank
you the motion re for us majority
committer report of inexpedient to
legisl House Bill 75 this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppos you'll
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
represent
all members present had an opportunity
vote 167 voting yay 190 voting aay the
motion fails representative Alesandra
Murray moves ought to pass are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I I oppose
nay the eyes have it and commit a report
order majority of the committee on
criminal justice and Public Safety to
which was referred House Bill 207 FN act
relative to repealing the prohibition on
the possession or sale of blackjacks
slungshot metallic Knuckles except by or
two miners having considered the same
report the same with a recommendation
that the bill ought to pass instead of
Jennifer roads for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered same being unable to
agree with a majority Report with the
following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Linda Harriet goth for the minority of
the committee chair recognizes
goth so we supposed to be doing P okay
Mr
Speaker if I know that blackjacks and
sling shots and metallic Knuckles are
weapons that continue to be used by
aggressors she speak to intimidate
terrorize representative hold
it speaking you're speaking not no it's
because we Pi no you're doing we okay
okay representative Granger has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote so we're
the motion before us majority committer
report of a to pass on House Bill
207 this is going to be a roll call vote
the chair recognized representative
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that the blackjacks slung
shots and metallic Knuckles are weapons
that continue to be used by aggressors
to intimidate terrorize and beauy ass
assault their
victims and if I know that additionally
they often associated with criminal
activities such as gang fights or
robberies and their very presence
typically leads to more violent
confrontations that would have occurred
without them and lastly if the minority
if I believe that the current law is in
place to protect the public and lifting
the probation proh prohibition on
possession and sale of these weapons
that's intended to Ma and Inspire fear
is not in the best interest of New
Hampshire's public
safety then I would press the red button
against the art to pass
motion chair recognize representative
Roy for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that we just voted because we
said we trust the people of New
Hampshire to have certain substances
would I not then also trust them to have
certain devices and if I know that the
Supreme Court has ruled that any weapon
can be a weapon within the meaning of
the Second Amendment it doesn't just
mean
firearms and if I know that we have
since these have been invented have
electric weapons people can use chemical
weapons but yet we still make it illegal
to have the weapon that Davy used to
beat Goliath would I not think that we
should update our
laws thank you the motion before us
majority committer report of autop pass
on House Bill 207 this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if your oppos your press
the red button voting stations are open
[Music]
represent
present all members present had an
opportunity to vote house attendance
vote 207 voting aay 162 V aay committee
for what reason does it the house will
be in
order for what reason does a member rise
thank you Mr Speaker it's getting a bit
toasty in here so I Rise to make a
motion to allow all of the hot men to
remove their
objection majority of the committee on
criminal justice and Public Safety to
FN an act establishing the crime of
criminal nect of a child having
considered the same report the same with
a recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative Terry Roy from the
majority of the
committee minority having considered the
same being unable to agree with the
majority Report with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate present a bud Shear for the
minority of the committee for what
reason does a member rise make a motion
Mr Speaker State your motion I move that
house bill uh 257 be recommitted to the
committee are you you ready for the
question the motion before
is a division has been requested members
the motion before us is to recommit
257 this is a division division vote
chair recognized pres Roy for a
parliamentary
inquiry Mr Speaker if I know that um on
both sides of the aisle there's some um
concerns regarding language that the
committee would like to take a second
look at to see if we can't get everybody
on board would I now vote to recommit
this the motion before us to recommit
House Bill 257 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press a green
button if you're opposed you'll press a
red button voting stations are open for
yes it won't because it's closed thumbs
up thank you very much representative
[Music]
Jones all members present had an
opportunity to vote also will attend to
vote 371 voting yay two voting nay
motion
passes chair recognize the clerk thank
you Mr Speaker this is just a polite
reminder that if you have not voted at
the expiration of the 30 seconds and I
call your name the voting station is
turned off and you cannot push a button
and have it recorded which is why I ask
you for a thumbs up or thumbs down thank
majority of the command of Criminal
Justice and Public Safety to which was
referred House Bill 352 FN an act
prohibiting possession of a firearm at a
polling place having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate representative Terry Roy
for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the recommendation to Bill L to pass
representative David Muse for the
minority of the committee chair
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I rise
today to oppose the inexpedient to
legislate recommendation on HB
352 on days when federal state or
Municipal elections are taking place
this bill would prohibit carrying a
deadly weapon either out in the open or
concealed within 100 ft of a polling
place the goal of the bill is pretty
simple to reduce the risk of our
citizens and our election workers from
being implicit l or explicitly
threatened with guns while taking part
in the most sacred of American
traditions sadly intimidation including
intimidation by armed civilians has long
been a tool that some have used to
prevent full participation in American
democracy during and after
reconstruction guns were often used to
scare black voters away from the
polls as our country becomes more
divided our sad and shame ful history of
armed voter intimidation and political
violence is being repeated during recent
election Cycles people have been
arrested for making death threats to
election workers and for setting fire to
vote dropboxes in Georgia and Michigan
during the 2020 election voters and
election workers faced intimidation and
threats of violence in Charlotte North
Carolina an armed man was arrested after
a polling supervisor asked him to leave
a polling place on Election Day and he
turn in Lane County Oregon armed
individuals reportedly approached people
as they were dropping off their
ballots while these incidents are
admittedly rare in New Hampshire it's
simply inaccurate to say that acts of
intimidation involving guns at polling
places don't happen in Manchester during
the November 2020 election an armed man
harassed people holding signs for
candidates in the election earing area
outside of three separate polling places
Behavior like this not only puts voters
and election workers at risk it puts
democracy itself at risk 22 states in
the district of Colombia already
explicitly prohibit guns at polling
places in some way unfortunately our
state does not under our current law
state and local authorities can't
prevent people from bringing guns into
polling places even those located in
school
buildings with HB 352 we have the power
to fix this and we have the
Constitutional authority to do so in the
heler decision Justice anonin Scalia
wrote that while the second amendment
protects the rights of law-abiding
responsible citizens to use arms in
defense of Hearth and Home he also wrote
that nothing in our opinion should be
taken to cast doubt on long-standing
prohibitions on laws prohibiting the
carrying of firearms in sensitive public
places such as Schools and Government
buildings several States including
Georgia have interpreted sensitive
places to include polling
places also worth pointing out is the
very same generation that added the
Second Amendment to the Constitution
also passed state laws prohibiting
bringing guns to the polls the authors
of the Delaware state constitution
written in 7
1776 at the time our country was founded
provided that no person shall come to a
polling place armed and no muster of the
militia shall be made on that day it
further provides that no Battalion or
company can come within a mile of a
polling place for 24 hours before or
after an
election the same year Maryland passed
an identical law New York followed suit
uh a decade later and more states have
added similar laws during Reconstruction
and also in the 20th century the bottom
line is this is not an anti-gun law as
some would frame it what it is is a a
Prov voter law that will reduce the risk
of armed intimidation from happening in
a place where it should never happen as
for the argument that bringing weapons
is necessary for self-defense there is
no record that I can find anywhere of a
good guy with a gun ever springing to
his own defense or to the defense of
others during a shooting inside a
polling place the bottom line is
bringing guns into a polling place does
nothing to promote election security or
to make anyone safer but what it does do
is intimidate lawful voters and risks
Bloodshed I ask you to vote red so
another motion can be made thank you
does the member yield to
questions no member does not yield chair
recognize representative
Roy thank you Mr Speaker um where to
start well I I thank my friend for
remembering um the the sad history of of
our country and he is correct is said
and when my party fought a war to end
slavery we ensured that everyone had
their second amendment rights still it
was the clan that tried to keep
African-Americans in the south from
owning firearms and it seems today it
hasn't stopped we encourage everyone
regardless of their Creed Color Race to
arm themselves and protect themselves
and defend themselves whether it's a
polling place or any other place I heard
him say I didn't hear one case of a good
guy with a gun well I haven't seen the
case of a bad guy with a gun at a
polling place in New Hampshire so I
don't care what other states did New
Hampshire is doing what New Hampshire
does and we are not going to limit the
rights of our citizens to defend
themselves in polling places or any
other place thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us is majority
committee report of anying speed to
legisl on House Bill 352 representative
Granger has requested a roll call that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
the motion the motion before us is the
majority committer report of inexpedient
to legislator on House Bill 352 this is
a roll call vote chair recognizes
representative Horgan for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you very much Mr Speaker
so find I know that polling places here
in New Hampshire are safe but if I also
know that our polling places will be
even safer if we pass HB
352 if I know this bill protects the
right of all voters including those who
do don't own any guns at all which is a
actually about two-thirds of the
population it's true um if I know that
22 States already have laws guaranteeing
safe folding places including four of
the five states which border the Gulf of
Mexico and perhaps closer to
home the house will be in
order closer to home the other two
states which border the Gulf of Maine
that's probably what we care about more
but regardless of whether your state
borders the Gulf of Mexico the Gulf of
Maine or any Gulf at all um I know that
this is a simple Common Sense Bill we
should have this in the granite
state so should I to make our poing
places even safer so would I then press
the red button so we can overturn the
itl and consider a more sensible motion
such as perhaps ought to pass anyway
first thing to do press red to overturn
the itl thank you chair recogniz
represent of
Roy Mr speaker thank you if I would not
take the advice of someone who does not
know geography
[Applause]
house will be in order would I then
support the committee on on this and
vote for the Gulf of America thank
you the motion before us majority
committer report of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 352 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
vote 21 voting yay 161 voting aay
majority committee on criminal justice
and Public Safety to which was referred
House Bill 381 FN an act exempting
firearms and Firearm accessories
manufactured for instate use only from
the national firearm act considered the
same report the same with a
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass pres of Matt sort D conier for the
majority of the
committee
minority having considered the same
being unable to agree with the majority
Report with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate it's in a Bud sheer for the
minority of the committee chair
Sher thank you Mr thank you Mr Speaker
um appreciate that I'm a recovering law
professor so I could talk to you about
the interstate commerce clause I could
talk to you about the latent Commerce
Clause I could talk to you about
whether a bill a a a gun that's
manufactured in New Hampshire is
manufactured with uh pieces material
that came from out of state and whether
that incl that makes it an interstate uh
item uh in spite of the fact that it's
manufacturing Hampshire but uh because
I'm trying to recover from being a
lesser I'm not going to talk to you
about that uh what this bill is really
about is to set up
litigation uh on the issue of uh the
interstate commerce clause and its
applicability uh I understand that that
litigation my my problem the problem
with this bill is it wants the state to
fund the litigation Private Industry
entities
could fund this litigation but they want
to pass on that they want the state the
Attorney General's office to spend their
uh money uh an underresourced office
they want the the Attorney General's
office the state to spend money uh to
fund this litigation which they must do
uh if this bill passes uh so I ask you
to uh press the red button and vote no
uh for and wait for another motion and I
ask for a division
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker this is
an interesting bill this is a bill that
was brought to us on the premise
that the United States Supreme Court in
the early 40s decided um that the use of
the Commerce Clause could expand the
federal government's authority to
regulate just about everything we own
and do and it's been continuing that way
for so long and we believe that it's
high time that the court take a second
look at it like it's stun with other
cases recently and decide again whether
or not the founders intended for the
United States Congress and its law
enforcement agencies to exert their
authority over every state in the
country and how we decide to do business
so we agree with that this bill should
be brought forward for that purpose and
um we ask you to support the committee
thank
you the motion before us majority
committee report of Auto pass on House
Bill 381 represent of Granger has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
the motion before us is a majority
committee report of Auto pass on House
Bill 381 this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes repres Sena of Newman for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that the sponsor of
the bill testified that the sole purpose
of this bill is to elicit a challenge in
the federal courts under the supremacy
clause and then he later on he in his
testimony he threw in the commer Clause
because that's really what he's trying
to attack and part of the Comm Clause is
the National Firearms
Act if I know this bill attempts to
succeed this challenge by restricting
the use of certain Firearms to the
confines of New Hampshire even though
the Supreme Court has repeatedly found
that regulating Firearms is
constitutional even when that firearm
activity occurs wholly within a single
state and if I know this bill will not
only diminish Public Safety but it will
put a heavy burden on the New Hampshire
attorney general if he chooses to pursue
this challenge would I now push the red
button so another motion can be made
thank you Mr Speaker the chair
recognizes representative Matt saborin
De
conier thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that the
enable right of the people to keep and
bear arms shall not be infringed and if
I know that a landowner should not have
to submit to federal regulations in
order to grow a private Garden on his
private property for personal use and if
I know that this principle should apply
to any product made for inate use then
would I press the green button and vote
yay on the OTP motion for HP
381 the motion before us is the majority
committee report of Auto pass on House
Bill 381 this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you press the
red button voting stations are open for
[Music]
while members present had an opportunity
vote 205 voting a 168 voting a committee
committee on criminal justice and Public
Safety to which was referred House Bill
778 FN an act authorizing the director
of the police standards and training
Council to detail Law Enforcement
Training specialist employed by the
council for law enforcement and crowd
control services having considered the
same and report and Report the same with
the following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment of Terry Roy for the
committee the amendment is 03
29h printed in house Record 12 page 39
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I iose
nay the eyes have it amendment is
adopted the motion before us now is
ought to pass with Amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those oppose nay the eyes
adopted committee on education funding
to which was referred house Bill 494 FN
act relative to the math learning
communities program making an
appropriation therefore having
considered the same report the same the
following Amendment and recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with
Amendment representative Rick lad for
the committee the amendment is
0172 printed in house Record 12 page 38
the question is on the amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I oppos nay the eyes have it
and the amendment is adopted the motion
before us now is a pass with Amendment
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I those OPP nay the eyes
have it and the committee report is
finance committee on education funding
to which was referred House Bill 716 FN
act making an appropriation for the Dual
and concurrent enrollment program
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment the
recommendation Bill ought to pass with
amendment in a rick lad for the
committee the amendment is 01 168h
printed in house Record 12 page 39 are
you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it the
amendment is adopted the motion before
us now is ought to pass with Amendment
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I those oppose nay the eyes
adopted and this is also going to
finance
majority of the committee on education
policy and administration to which was
referred House Bill 76 FN act relative
to tracking special education complaints
having considered the same report the
same with a recommendation the bill
ought to pass presentive Lisa Freeman
from the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolu res olution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate pegy B Bon from the minority
of the committee the chair recognizes
Bon thank you Mr Speaker I rise today in
opposition to
hb76 which pertains to tracking special
education
complaints navigating the special
education process can be difficult and
contentious for parents once a child is
identified is having a disability and
needing special services in the
classroom parents and School District
educators will meet as a team to develop
an individual education plan for the
student most often both the school
district and the parent agree on the
plan and it is
signed occasionally the parent will
disagree with the plan and refuse to
sign the I
AP if informal methods to come to an
agreement fail
the parent May file a complaint and the
dispute resolation resolution process
begins in March of
2024 the office of the legislative
budget assistant released a performance
audit report of the dispute resolution
processes in the New Hampshire
Department of special
education many issues within the
department were
identified including deficiencies with
effectively maintaining and tracking
student
data last session legislation was signed
into law to address some of these broad
concerns the office of the advocate for
special education and the special
education department are expanding their
efforts to improve parent access to
relevant resources to assist them in
helping their children receive Services
identified in their individual education
plans
hb76 was brought forward to better align
New Hampshire state law with current
dispute resolution
procedures the New Hampshire Department
of Education is reviewing upgraded
tracking software to improve
recordkeeping of the dispute resolution
processes tracking data and transparency
to the public are
important but must be done carefully and
with respect to individual privacy
concerns
much of the information required in hp76
is duplicative and already posted on the
Department of Education website with
personally identifiable information
redacted there is also an analysis of
Trends and data relative to the 2024
complaints moreover some of the required
types of data listed in
hb76 lack context and could easily be
misinterpreted for example it requires
the Department of Education to publicly
identify individual school
districts this raises serious student
privacy concerns as there are typically
less than 40 cases in the State per year
if there is only one complaint in a
school district it is quite likely that
a student's identity could be
hb76 is intended to provide a Statewide
guide to how the federal IGA law should
be interpreted but it overshoots that
Mark and could compromise the privacy of
both School personnel and individual
students legislation has already been
passed to give the office of the
advocate for special education access to
all relevant data to better assist with
parent complaints
and The Advocate is the one best
equipped to handle such sensitive
information involving parent
complaints there is no need to publicly
post all of this
data I urge you to protect our students
privacy and vote no on the out to pass
motion Mr Speaker I ask for a division
thank you Mr Speaker good afternoon
colleagues I speak today in support of
hb76 which is relative to tracking
special education
complaints colleagues this bill merely
increases transparency while ensuring
privacy on data the doe currently
collects it does not Place undue
hardship on the doe or create additional
work it does not infringe on the
protection of personally identifiable
information as opponents of this bill
purport and is in full compliance with
furpa the family educational rights and
Privacy Act Additionally the opponents
of this bill have stated in small school
districts children will be easily
identified the notion that this bill
exposes a child with a documented
disability is not only unfounded but a
spasmodic response given the amount of
complaints received by legislators
around
transparency this Bill merely seeks to
address that issue in a timely secure
crystalline manner thank
you the motion before us majority
committee report of Auto pass on House
Bill 76 a division has been requested
the motion before us is a majority
committee report of Auto pass on House
Bill 76 this is a division vote chair
recognize representative Cornell for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this bill duplicates work that has
already been done and is presently
available on the Department of Education
website and if I know that this bill
tracks special education complaints but
does nothing to address them or follow
through on a complaint and if I know
that in a small District it would be
easy to identify who made the complaint
in New Hampshire student privacy is a
priority and strictly protected it is
not the kind of transparency that we are
looking for would I now press the red
button to make sure student privacy is
protected thank you chair recognized
from senat cordall for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know geography and if I also know
that the Department of Education has
started posting complaint findings as a
results of an audit last year but if I
know that more information should be
available such as the law firms involved
in the due process hearings wouldn't it
be interesting to see what law firms are
working against parents and if I know
that this bill is about transparency for
due process hearings where parents are
challenging the district for services
offered for their child with
disabilities what I now vote ought to P
pass by pressing the green
button the motion before us majority
committee report of Auto pass on House
Bill 76 this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if your opposer press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
than
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state of
the
vote 208 voting a 161 voting a the
adopted all the members stay in your
seats we got a vote coming right up we
got a uh just a division vote coming
right up the majority of the committee
on Election law to which was referred
House Bill 107 an act relative to
political advertising printed in
newspapers periodicals or Billboards
consider the same report the same with a
recommendation to Bill ought to pass sen
robbert Ry from the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution that is
inexpedient to leg legislate Senor
Russell mad for the minority of the
committee this is a division vote
the motion before us majority committee
report of aut to pass on House Bill 107
this is a division vote the chair
recognizes representative Mirad for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that our longstanding very
longstanding requirement that political
advertising be labeled as such has
caused no burden to anyone ever has
caused no practical problem to any
campaign or person or interest ever if I
know that the techniques the digital
techniques of manipulation and
deception get more
sophisticated every hour and if I know
that a eliminating the requirement to
label political advertising as political
advertising will give rise to a
tsunami of
misinformation and
deception then would I press the red
button chair recognize representative
Barry for a parliamentary inquiry thank
you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that
I'm not sure that that Pi by the other
member was about this bill um and Mr
Speaker if I know that this is about
removing the requirement that newspapers
specifically have an added disclaimer
and Mr Speaker if I know that political
advertisements will still require the
disclaimer would I now vote green to
remove this arbitrary requirement for
newspapers for a bill that last year
passed on
consent the motion before us is ought to
pass on House Bill 107 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
represent
Richards all members president had an
opportunity to vote house attend to stay
vote 209 voting a 162 voting a committee
adopted committee on Election lot to
which was referred House Bill 327 FN an
act relative to filing for office and
witnessing affidavit having considered
the same report the same with the
following Amendment the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with
Amendment represent Ros Berry for the
committee the amendment is 0237 H
printed in house Record 12 pages 36- 37
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it the
amendment is adopted the motion before
us now is ought to pass with Amendment
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I those oppos nay the
adopted majority of the committee on
fishing game and Marine Resources to
which is referred House Bill 61 and act
creating a committee to study the laws
relative to Oyster harvesting having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate sen Jonathan
Smith for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass presentive Katherine Harvey for
the minority of the committee the chair
Fox thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker this
bill is a simple one all it does is
create a study committee to evaluate
oyster farming in the Great Bay the
committee would gather opinions from a
variety of sources oyster Farmers Dees
Fish and Game law enforcement and land
of
Butters over the years 95% of the
oysters in the Great Bay have been lost
that's cost the Great Bay one of its
most valuable sources of filtration one
oyster can filter 40 to 50 gallons per
day so it adds up pretty quickly oysters
could filter the entire grape Bay in
about 4
days a thriving oyster farming industry
will also have economic benefits for the
state as a huge Jimmy Buffett
fan I dream of having oysters and beer
for dinner every day of the year
to make my oyster dream a reality and
strengthen our economy please press the
red button so a better motion can be
vote chair recogniz representative
explain thank you Mr
Speaker as the other speaker said this
is a very simple bill it's looking for a
study committee unfortunately the study
doesn't need to be
done our committee took a field trip out
to Great Bay and little Bay last term
and we got to see many currently
functioning oyster farms on those bodies
there are between 11 and 14 different
businesses right now doing the oyster
farming on Great Bay and little Bay and
they have allocated property through the
current proper channels that they can
now continue seeding and and farming in
they've never asked for any more to be
allocated yet nor have any new people
asked asking to be able to farm there
been denied the opportunity to farm
there so there's nothing broken in the
current system it's working fine and
when people want to add more oyster
farms or do more oyster farming they
have an Avenue to ask for that and we
don't need a study committee to do it I
ask you to vote green and support the
bipartisan majority committee opinion
thank
you the motion before us a majority
committee report of any week to
legislator and house bill 61 this is a
the motion before us majority committee
report of inexpedient to legislator on
House Bill 61 this is a division vote
chair recognizes representative Harvey
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that we
have lost 95% of all of our oysters in
the Great Bay um area which is why no
one is re applying for more oyster farms
and that hurts not only our oyster
farming a aquaculture culture but also
the waters the conservation of the
Waters of Great Bay because a healthy
oyster Farm
filters uh the Great Bay Waters every
four days and Mr Speaker if I know that
this bill establishes a simple study
committee for a very complex problem
that involves Dees fishing game oyster
Farmers Landa Butters law enforcement
and others just to name a few and if I
know that this bill is supported by the
fish and game department would I now
press the red button thank you Mr
Speaker chair recogniz represent wette
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that the oysters that
are being farmed right now are coming
from UNH and are not natural they're
implanted there
and if I know that we currently have a
growing profitable oyster industry and
it has guidance and oversight from Dees
and fishing game and if I know creating
a committee to discuss o oyster harvests
without the input of Dees and fishing
game is not prudent and not needed then
I would push the green button and uphold
the itl
motion thank you the motion before us
majority committee report of inexpedient
to legislate on House Bill 61 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press green button if your opposer press
the red button voting stations are open
[Music]
all members present have an opportunity
vote 209 voting a 161 voting aay the
committee on Health and Human Services
and Elder Affairs to which was referred
House Bill 53 an act permitting
qualifying patients and designated
caregivers to cultivate cannabis for
therapeutic use consider the same report
the same with the following Amendment
and the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass with Amendment
committee the amendment is 027 2H
printed in house Record 12 page 32 are
you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I iOS
nay the amendment is adopted
representative Granger has requested a
seconded yeah it is sufficiently
the motion before us is a pass as
amended on House Bill 53 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
[Music]
representative Schmidt representative BL
Ross
represent
while members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
vote 328 voting a 42 voting a committee
adopted majority committee on Judiciary
to which was referred House Bill 66 FN
an act relative to material subject to
disclosure under the right to no law
having considered the same report the
same with the following Amendment and
the recommendation to Bill a to pass
with Amendment Representative Bob Lind
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legisl
committee the amendment is
0110 printed in house Record 12 page 32
through 33 are you ready for the
question on the amendment all those in
favor say I I those oppose nay the eyes
adopted we have a division on the bill
know
the motion before us is aut to pass with
Amendment on House Bill 66 FN this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you press the red button voting stations
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
vote 321 voting aay 48 voting nay the
majority and Committee of Judiciary to
which was referred House Bill 80 en act
allowing a public body member's Presence
at a meeting by electronic or by other
means of communication only if physical
presence is unavoidable in providing
that physical presence is necessary for
voting having considered the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate reprentative marjerie Smith
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority of Report with
the following Amendment the
recommendation to Bill aut to pass with
Amendment pres of Joe Alexander for the
minority of the committee the chair
turkot thank you Mr
Speaker the majority vote of itl in the
calendar is a result of the committee's
voting on hb80 in its entirety and that
contained uh two separate parts one of
the parts the majority of the committee
found unworkable and therefore you got
the itl
recommendation in the calendar there is
a committee amendment that removes that
unworkable piece so I ask that you vote
read on this itail motion so that the
amendment can be introduced discussed
and considered thank you Mr
Speaker chair recognize representative
thank you Mr
Speaker the this bill is a bill that
each one of us has to deal with in many
different
configurations um in our
counties um in our towns in our cities
it is a very serious problem we all know
that you know a lot more if you show up
than if you don't this bill um while we
had great Sympathy for the sponsor of
the bill and someone who comes from my
County um it would apply to every single
agency that is covered by
91a that means not just towns and cities
it means everything else and it would
indeed create this unworkable system of
some people counting and some people not
and words that are not very clear like
unavoidable I'm not sure exactly what
unavoidable means the
amendment was
clear um presented to the committee the
committee did not accept the
amendment the vote in the committee was
13-4 overwhelmingly supporting the bill
and uh the the majority of itl and on
behalf of the 13 members of the
committee from both parties I ask you to
support the committee and vote itl and
let's find another vehicle to try to
address this problem that cannot not be
resolved in the way that the sponsor
you the motion before Force majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislator and House Bill
80 speak representative turkot has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
not
the motion before us a majority
committer report of any speeding to
legisla on House Bill 80 this is a roll
call vote if you're chair recognized
representative Alexander for a
parliamentary inquir thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know there are
some parts of this bill that are
unworkable but there is a minority
Amendment that will fix the bill and get
it to a point where we can pass it as
ought to pass as Amendment would I then
press red so that we can pass this Bill
thank
you chair recognize representative
marjerie Smith for parliamentary
inquiry Mr Speaker if I know and I think
you all agree that the world is not
perfect and we don't have all the time
available for every Bill if we know that
the overwhelming majority of this
committee gave a lot of time to consider
the merits of the bill and consider the
proposed amendments and voted 13
to4 um would I now say that the train
has left the station and we ought to
just accept the overwhelming committee
vote and move on to the next
bill the motion before us majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislator and House Bill 80 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're oppos
you'll press the red button voting
[Music]
representative
Murray all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
vote 179 voting a 190 voting a the
representative Alexander moves minority
amendment to pass off a to he moves
ought to pass off and offers minority
Amendment
022 7h printed in house Record 12 page
to speak against you want to speak
offering chair recognizes representative
marjerie
Smith to speak against the amendment
I would like to suggest that if you care
at all about local
control you would not support an
amendment which would
bind all kinds of entities to follow
what is
required and I would urge you to vote
against the amendment and and in favor
of a committee which gave this bill due
diligence and which
overwhelmingly believed that the bill
should be itl with the amendment or with
thank
you J recognize represent turkot
speaking for his Amendment thank you Mr
Speaker I res in supported the amendment
uh 2024 312 uh 12h as originally drafted
as I spoke a few minutes ago hbad
contained two specific changes to the
rsas the second change would have
permitted only permitted voting on those
public body members physically in
attendance however the testimony and the
executive committee discussion indicated
the potential for problems in the case
of a very small public body I agreed
with that I I do agree with that this is
part of this is the part of the uh bill
that has been removed in the floor
Amendment now the first part remains in
as the entirety of what you will now be
voting on in the floor Amendment and
that is would continue the practice of
allowing remote participation by a
member of the body but it would require
a higher hurdle needed for such remote
attendance currently the attendance bar
is set in the rsas by the phrase quote
not being reasonably practical which is
uh very very
subjective the remaining piece of hb80
would amend that term with put in its
place the term
unavoidable physical attendance at a
public meeting should be Paramount
except under the most difficult
circumstances we do not want to water
down Decades of our pre of Precedence
under the current and the proposed rsas
the chairman of the body would still
render the decision on what is to be
considered unavoidable I ask that you
support the minority opinion and vote
green on the the floor Amendment thank
Speaker the motion before us is the
0312 are you ready for the
question a division has been requested
[Music]
some
the motion before us is minority
Amendment
0312 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposer press the red button
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
vote 190 voting a 179 voting a minority
committee amendment is
adopted now we're on aop pass as
amended a division has been requested
members stay in your seats or take your
seats
what what reason does a member
arise we're in the voting mode right now
Ive
all members present had an opportunity
vote I got distracted I
apologize the motion before us now is
the motion of autop pass as amended on
House Bill
80 this is a division
vote I think I got it right this time
so all if you're in favor you'll press
the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button vot voting
sylvestro have all members present had
an opportunity to vote house will attend
188 voting aay 181 voting aay committee
adopted committee on Judiciary to which
was referred House Bill 111 FN act
extending the position of right to know
Omni budsman for two years considered
the same report the same with the
following Amendment recommendation Bill
Auto pass with Amendment sen of Caitlyn
cutab for the commit
the amendment is
0170 printed in house Record 12 page 34
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
committee amendment is adopted the
motion before us now is ought to pass
with Amendment are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the committee report is
Finance majority of the committee on
labor industrial and reab rehabilitative
services to which was referred House
Bill 282 FN act increasing the maximum
benefits for the First Responders
critically injured in the line of duty
we considered the same report the same
with the following resolution resolved
that is inexpedient to legislate
representative Mark Warden from the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass pres of Timothy Susi for the
minority of the committee chair
recognizes
representative representative
against thank you Mr Speaker I stand
before for you to speak against the itl
motion on House Bill what is this
282 um what this bill does is it
increases the maximum benefits for our
first responders that includes police
officers firefighters and so on
currently the maximum benefit is
$500,000 a bium uh for critically
injured members of those
departments what happens is God forbid
we have a mass shooting or a severe fire
where several members of the Departments
get injured if we have a maximum of
$500,000 that could be eaten through
very quickly um under this bill it would
still require governor and executive
Council approval but it would increase
it from $500,000 maximum to $1 million
the maximum benefit per member is only
$125,000 per
claimant um and what this does the Ben
critical injury benefit provides
compensation to Firefighters police
officers and correctional officers who
sustain permanent impairments from on
duty injuries to inter internal organs
or senses I mean I stand before I run on
a backing the blue P platform and
supporting our First Responders and I
think the least we can do is increase
the benefits God forbid they are injured
in the line of duty I recommend
everybody votes against this it L motion
Warden thank you Mr
Speaker the previous speaker references
the chapter in rsa's 281a which does
apply to certain group two retirement
system employees designated as First
Responders and what it does is allow for
additional payments to Injured Workers
on top of the standard workers comp
payments these are for very serious
impairments or loss of use of internal
organs as you heard the cap is currently
$125,000 per injured employee that is
not changed and that's not uh challenge
in this particular Bill what we're
talking about this bill would seek to
increase uh the maximum amount per bium
from 500,000 and double it to $1 million
we he from the Department of Labor said
the current cap of $500,000 has not been
tested the most they had in a 2-year
period was
$350,000 for this particular fund so the
committee does believe that it's
unnecessary at this time we have no
demonstrable need for this increase
further if there were to be some sort of
mass uh injuries event Black Swan event
certainly this body or the governor and
executive counsel could find ways to uh
supplement the fund through one offs and
not to even consider great things like
gofund me and other private sector
options so for th those reasons uh the
committee encourages you to vote itl
thank
you the motion before us a majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill
282 are you ready for the question the
division has been requested members take
Calles representative Burch requested a
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
clear
the motion before us majority commit
report of inexpedient to legisl on
houseal Bill
282 this is going to be a roll call vote
chair recognized representative Susi for
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that law
enforcement firefighting and Corrections
are inherently dangerous professions and
if I know that in these professions that
serious injuries can occur without
notice leading to extensive Medical
treatment Rehabilitation and long-term
care and if I also know that some of
these injuries can lead to these First
Responders unable to return to work
leading to loss of income and financial
hardship and finally Mr Speaker if I
believe that we should affirm our
commitment to protecting those who
protect us but I now press the red
button to overturn the committee's
report of it thank you Mr Speaker chair
recognize representative warden for a
parliamentary
inqu thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if
I know that the fund has not even hit
the current statutory limit of $500,000
per bonam for total payouts of
additional compensation so there's no
demonstrated need for this change and if
I know that in a belt-tightening
budgetary envir environment this
doubling of an underutilized fund is not
prudent and if I know that even in a
Black Swan event with many injuries
there will be plenty of creative private
and public offers of financial help to
victims First Responders that are likely
Superior to this particular fund
and finally Mr Speaker if I know the
committee values the dangerous work of
our First Responders in the state but
knows that this bill isn't a solution
would I now support the committee
recommendation by pressing the green
button thank you the motion before us
majority commit a report of an expedient
to legislator on House Bill 282 this is
a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you press the red button voting
[Music]
represent
Stone if all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
vote 175 voting a 195 voting a the
committee report fails representative
Susi moves ought to
pass are you ready for the question a
division has been requested members take
your stay take your seats or stay in
your
seats yeah it's overturn to rec to
finance
the motion before us is a to pass on
House Bill 282 they say division vote if
you're in favor you'll press a green
button if your opposer press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
for
[Music]
represent represent LE Lee and
Bone all members present had an
were all members president had an
opportunity to vote how will tend to
vote 202 voting yay 169 voting nay
minority committee report is
adopted it's going to and it's going to
finance
majority committee on labor industrial
and realtive services to which was
referred House Bill 299 FN an act
relative to the award of attorneys fees
and cost and workers compensation claims
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate Senor Brian Le for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative Mark McKenzie for
the minority of the committee chair
McKenzie thank you Mr
Speaker I rise in opposition to the
recommendation of the committee in
expedient to
legislate the workers compensation
system in New Hampshire protects the
business community and it protects the
workers the basis for workers
compensation is that employees give up
the right to sue their employers and in
exchange for that they're giving a
system of
benefits that provide that they return
to work when they can and if they can't
they are
supported now an injured worker
currently has a couple of choices when
the insurance company decides to deny
that claim
they can file for a hearing before the
the Department of
Labor and they go in
prosay represent themselves or they can
hire at their own uh their own expense
an attorney to represent them in the
hearing
expensive this bill looks to level the
playing field in every other step in the
work is compensation system the claim it
if they Prevail can get the cost of the
attorney fees reimbursed only if they
Prevail and that's what this bill
does it allows them to recover that
particular thing from the insurance
company and the the idea is that this
would level the playing field I don't
want to say insurance companies are
denying claims intentionally I have no
evidence to show that but it clearly
puts them in a an injured worker in a a
very difficult
position so all this says is you go to
you have a hearing you go there you're
an injured worker and you and you
Prevail you get paid now let me say this
the Department of Labor did uh provided
the committee with some
statistics and what they said is that of
those people who
appeal half of the people who file for
appeal withdraw the
appeal but they said those people who
hire at their own expense Attorneys at
the first level for they Prevail 45% of
the time so having an attorney makes a
difference because when you show up at
the first level hearing and you show up
by yourself you're going to be squaring
off against an attorney who is an expert
in the area of workers compensation it's
clearly an unfair advantage that the
insurance companies have as I said we
had this problem a few years ago when it
came to medical bills recovering medical
bills and we we corrected that this
legislature corrected that because it
wasn't an attorney around that would
take the case because the way attorneys
work and work his compensation is a
contingency thing that's how they work
so all this says is if you Prevail you
can file for for the uh ability to get
re reimburse your medical bills no more
than 20% of the of the settlement
because that's governed by the
department of Labor and I think this
moves it in the right direction so my
colleagues I know it's late and I don't
uh want to disrespect my uh Republican
members of the committee who voted
inexpedient to legislate but I would ask
this committee to think about Injured
Workers and what they face and to try as
best we can to level a playing field for
them and I think if we vote this down if
you vote against this amendment the
inexpedient to legislate and come give
us an opportunity come back so that's my
uh request Mr chairman and I ask for a
Bri thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I
rise in opposition of House Bill 299 due
to the negative impacts it would have on
the workers comp hearing process this
bill is problematic for three reasons
number one increased litigation by
automatically awarding attorneys fees in
costs this bill encourages unnecessary
legal action making litigation the first
Resort rather than the last number two
financial burden higher Insurance costs
for employers would likely result from
the Bill's suggested mandate and lastly
unclear cost
responsibility the Department of Labor
has noted there is an uncertainty as to
who would ultimately pay these fees and
costs this could lead to both legal and
administrative challenges ultimately
affecting taxpayers
this bill has the potential to cause far
more problems than it solves colleagues
I urge you to vote itl by pressing the
Speaker the motion before us is majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislator and House Bill 299 division a
division has been requested members take
speaker
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legisl on House Bill 299 this is going
to be a division vote chair recognized
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I believe that this legislation is a
crucial step in ensuring that Injured
Workers are provided with the necessary
legal representation to claim their
rightful benefits under the law if I
also believe that this legislation would
level the playing field between the
injured worker and the insurance
companies and Mr Speaker finally if I
know that this legislation would
reimburse the injured worker if they
Prevail at the department level would I
now press the red button to overturn the
committee's report of itl thank you Mr
Speaker chair recognize representa flan
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that Workers Compensation
Insurance was established to protect the
employee from work related
injuries and if I know that by adding
legal expenses on any medical expense
the cost of that insurance is going to
go up and we know who's going to pay for
that in the long run the
consumers and Mr Speaker if I know that
the fee that inter attorneys can charge
is at 20% of any money's recovered not
the 33% or 50% that people hear about on
contingency cases and finally Mr
Speaker if I know there's an utsman at
the Department of Labor that can help
potential claimants would I now vote
green to support the itl thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us is the
majority committee report of
inexperience to legisl on House Bill 299
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're oppos you'll press a red button
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state of
the
vote 193 voting aay 177 voting a
adopted majority of committee on labor
industrial and reability of service to
which was referred House Bill 586 FN act
establish an employee assistance program
for small town First Responders and
making an appropriation therefore having
considered the same report the same the
following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate s of Steves
kessle ring for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the recommendation the bill ought to
pass represent Brian Sullivan for the
minority of the committee for what
reason does a member rise
thank you Mr Speaker I Rise to make a
motion State your motion I'd like to
table HP
586 that is a proper motion the motion
586 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say i i n the eyes have
it and House Bill 586 is laid on the
table
would everybody stay in your seats for
just a minute so we can get through the
third reading motion and there are some
you the chair recognized a member from
Auburn representative Osborne for the
third reading motion thank you resolve
that the house now adjourned from the
early session that the business of the
late session be in order at the present
time that the reading of bills be by
title only in resolutions by caption
only that all bills ordered to third
reading be read a third time by this
resolution and that all titles of bills
be the same is adopted and that they be
passed at the present time and when the
house adjourns today it be to meet
Thursday March 6th at 10: a.m. all those
in favor say
iose n the eyes have it the motion is
adopted house will attend to
announcements chair recognize
thank you Mr Speaker members of Criminal
Justice um the following house bills
59159 and 592 that are going to be exact
tomorrow will be open in recess and the
recess will be until next Wednesday at
10:
thank you Mr Speaker announcement
emerging Technologies caucus is going to
meet tomorrow by teams 11 o'clock
tomorrow Friday if you're a member of
the caucus you should have got a
calendar invite if you have trouble with
it please see me we're going to be
talking about blockchain tomorrow so it
should be
interesting chair recognize
representative
wer thank you Mr the speaker brother
Masons members of the fraternity of
Masons on the third Thursday we normally
meet for General Court Lodge I've not
been able to make arrangements to use
their building but I would like us to
meet I've made arrangements to have a
room at the Common Man for us to meet
together and have a dinner but I didn't
think we'd be out this early we can
probably push the reservation I made by
meeting at 4:30 4:30 for the general
court Court Lodge and any other Masons
who are newly joined to this body and
don't know about General Court Lodge so
at the common man out just before the
underpass um at
4:30 um we'll ask for the meeting in the
governor's room thank you chair
recognizes the clerk thank you Mr
Speaker just a a reminder as we will not
be in session next week uh please empty
your seat pockets and if you have a um
over overflowing box in the back uh we
would encourage you to empty that as
well thank you Mr Speaker representative
hurn M moves that the house stand in
recess for the purpose of introduction
to bills vacate motions Ro Bill
amendments and Ro Bill reports and
receiving messages are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I those
oppos nay the eyes have it and the house
in recess until Thursday March 6 2025 at
10: